as you know each week we get these
numbers from the office for national
statistics they show us the number of
people who have died not just a covert
nineteen but of all causes as well and
this is the most comprehensive sense of
of how many people have sadly lost their
lives during the course of this pandemic
and I'm afraid the bad news is that
those excess deaths as they're often
called so the number of people dying
above the historical average are still
rising so the death toll from this virus
is still going up the good news is it's
going up a less quick rate than it has
done earlier but let me just show you
some of the figures so you get a sense
of this the numbers by the way from the
ons that we get this morning off for
England and Wales but what I've done is
I've put them together with numbers we
also have from Northern Ireland and from
Scotland so we get a picture for the
whole of the UK and what this shows us
as follows that line there shows you the
average number of people who have died
in given months of the year over the
course of the last five years so that's
your kind of 5-year average and let's
bring on what's happened so far this
year and you can see the big rise in
deaths and this is deaths from all
causes across the UK have over that
period you can see Kovach 19 has
definitely been a part of that about 80
percent of that is down to cope of 19
but what you see is here where we are at
the moment towards the right-hand side
of that chart the gap between those two
lines is narrowing so the number of
people who are dying at the moment above
the historical average is down to the
lowest level since the early part of
this crisis and if you look across a
hold of the UK if you cut just in
England and well that's 732 across the
whole of the UK you're talking about 802
excess deaths and by my calculations
where we are at the moment in in terms
of total deaths all because we're kind
of getting closer to that point when
those two lines touch we will be able to
say well we are kind of getting closer
to the idea of a death toll from Kobe 19
so far the number of deaths that are put
down to kovat 19 are just under 52,000
across the whole of the UK by my
calculations and excess deaths so when
you're taking all causes is up to sixty
four thousand five hundred one other
point that's worth making because we
also get data on where those deaths have
taken place have a look at this this
line here they're like how high knee
lines I'll show you show you excess
debts and different settings so at home
in hospitals and in care homes now we
all know that care homes have being the
epicenter for quite some time but what
concerns me now is the fact that
actually we're seeing more deaths at
home so in domestic settings than we are
in care homes and that number is
actually going up so potentially people
dying of covert 19 or other causes above
the historical average at home